I am so excited thank you such a
wonderful evening it's insane but it's
beautiful I'm so happy
describe you're looking one word
fabulous honey you understand your
fiance is with you tonight yes he's here
he's here he's wonderful did that make
the night even more special of course to
share it with the one that you loved you
know it's just a beautiful evening and
he was so supportive through the entire
filming process and you know I love him
very much
What did he say to you about tonight is
he just so proud he said enjoy yourself
[Music]
look at the stunning date you have those
should expect a cuter
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Monique Lhullier and I am so
thrilled right now I am comfortable I
feel it's about two pockets I'm just
happy with that there you go I love it
I'm not worried about my hair it's all
very relaxed
[Music]
it literally it might be the dress of
all the dreams I've ever had about
dresses it was not a heart decision it's
a custom so it was built and it fits
like a glove I'm very very happy
[Music]
this is you here yes it is and yes it is
he knows what he's doing
[Music]
blimey thank you so much um
I'm not going to cry because my entire
table will point laughs at me
I want to thank our DP Jessica Lagaan
yay
a woman DP bring it on
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much to the HF PA I
didn't see this coming at all
[Music]
you
[Music]